[Music]
sometimes the smallest things can pack
the biggest punch if you were swept up
in the Grandeur of the quantum realm you
may have missed these small but
important bits of story and Ant-Man and
the wasp quantumania
Scott Lang's brief employment at Baskin
Robbins is one of the first jokes in the
Ant-Man series and it factored heavily
into the marketing for quantumania in
the first film when Scott is unable to
get a job anywhere else he applies to
the ice cream chain using a fake name
Jack he gets a gig but almost
immediately loses it when his boss finds
out he lied on his application and that
he's actually a notorious burglar he
found out Baskin Robbins always finds
out however as much of a rule follower
as he might be manager Dale respects
Scott for sticking it to the Man and
tells him to steal a smoothie as he's
leaving flash forward to the beginning
of the mcu's phase 5 and Scott's life
has changed considerably he's become a
celebrity especially in his home city of
San Francisco Scott is honored as Baskin
Robbins employee of the century he
attends a ceremony with a returning Dale
wearing his Ant-Man suit but if you look
closely at the plaque on the wall the
photo is one of a listless Scott wearing
a name tag that says Jack ovarian Jack
shows up in his Baskin-Robbins uniform
when the real Ant-Man gets caught in a
probability storm while trying to help
Kang resize the fuel source for a ship
later a nervous day ale misspells the
word birthday on Cassie's inedible ice
cream cake
after playing an important role in the
events of Avengers end game Scott has
embarked in a career as immediate
personality and eagle-eyed viewers have
been noticing it in various recent MCU
offerings and Hawkeye an actor plays
Ant-Man in the musical theater
adaptation of the Battle of New York
who's there he knew it wasn't there
who's that guy
[Music]
the battle's Just Begun Kamala Khan
mentions a podcast interview Scott did
on a show called this powered life in
the first episode of Miss Marvel a
promotional spot for his Memoir look out
for the little guy even shows up on the
news crawl during Anderson Cooper's CNN
broadcast and black panther wakanda
forever while he may have once been
stuck under house arrest Ant-Man is now
arguably the most publicly visible
living Avenger Scott's spending more
time on his personal brand than on
saving the world is a key part of the
plot of Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
at least from Cassie's perspective dad
are you listening to your own book but I
was ready for it no that's uh Steven
this is the radio it's also another
running joke from his family's reactions
we can tell he talks about his book a
lot and that he's bought into his own
celebrity perhaps a little more than he
should have however Marvel is hoping
Scott's appeal extends beyond the MCU
and into our world and our timeline fans
can currently pre-order a real copy of
Scott Lang's look out for the little guy
though they'll apparently have to wait
all the way until September 5th 2023 to
actually read the 256 page fictional
autobiography we're sure it'll be a
riveting read
Scott first met Jimmy Wu and the former
member of Shield turned FBI agent was
assigned to his case after he ran afoul
of the sacovia Accords though Scott's
ex-wife Maggie gets annoyed whenever
Jimmy comes barging in during Scott's
house arrest the Lawman and the
lawbreaker have a friendlier
relationship and their circumstances
would suggest Wu was fascinated by
Scott's close-up magic tricks a skill
Scott taught himself with the help of
online videos during his sentence as
Ant-Man and the WASP plays out Jimmy can
be seen watching the same videos and
trying out the same tricks when Scott's
sentence is up Jimmy says he'll probably
have to arrest him again someday but he
also half-heartedly invites him to hang
out when Wu appears again in one
division he uses close-up magic to
introduce himself to Monica Rambo having
finally mastered Scott's routine Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania pays off this
ongoing bit beautifully when Scott Lang
performs the same trick with a credit
card as an offer to pay for woop's meal
it seems these one-time adversaries have
put the past behind them after all
[Music]
the snap at the end of Avengers Infinity
war was the biggest thing to happen in
the MCU and its effects continue to
reverberate throughout the franchise
early in Phase 4 the blip in which half
of humanity was wiped out was treated as
a global humanitarian crisis we saw how
it affected Monica Rambo who lost her
mother to cancer a sword fell into the
hands of Tyler Hayward we also saw how
the flag Smashers posed problems for
governments when large numbers of
refugees were displaced after the
reappearance of those who'd been lost
five years before but as the post
Infinity Saga MCU continued each project
reckoned with the blip a little less now
Cassie has taken up the cause of the
disenfranchised she's not a flag Smasher
but she does mention how the reversal of
the blip worsened San Francisco's
already dire housing affordability
problem near the start of Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania Scott gets a call
from jail after Cassie's been arrested
while protesting the removal of unhoused
people from public spaces she's wearing
a t-shirt with a graphic of planet Earth
on it which could indicate the Cassie
fancies herself an environmental
activist but it could also mean she
believes in something like the flag
smash anti-nationalist philosophy even
if Scott's idealistic teenage daughter
isn't officially affiliated with any
political organization her concern is
proof that the blip is a problem that is
yet to be completely resolved
in the Ant-Man movies it isn't just our
heroes that shrink and grow enlarged Pez
dispensers huge seeming toy trains as
well as miniaturized motor vehicles and
multi-story Office Buildings all get put
to use in creative ways thanks to Hank's
technology the most recognizable
large-scale prop might be the PIM Family
Home a distinctive three-level Victorian
with a corner spire and ornate gold trim
the pit Mouse isn't just pretty to look
at it becomes important to the plot of
the first film when Hank sets up Scott
to break in so that the inventor can
assess the x-con skills we broke into
this spooky ass house didn't we I let
you by the end of the second movie when
Janet returns after 30 years in the
quantum realm only to find her daughter
and husband wanted by the FBI family
downsizes literally and relocates the
house to the beach unfortunately Hank
Janet and hope all become victims of the
snap while Scots is in the quantum realm
meaning the beautiful home sits vacant
for five years things appear to be back
to normal at the start of Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania as Hank Janet hopes
Scott and Cassie all share a super-sized
pizza around the dinner table the house
which is a real property in San
Francisco's hate Ashbury Neighborhood
has returned to roughly its original
location
a recurring MCU visual Motif that began
a while ago and continues into phase 5
is gold rings Doctor Strange's sling
ring and the portals it opens as well as
the architecture of the sanctum
sanctorum fit in with this theme so do
Shang Chi's 10 rings and kamalacons
bangles likewise Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania is full of shiny round
imagery much of which is likely inspired
by the comics the setting tone and
visual style of the third Ant-Man
represents a noticeable departure from
the first two films which were more
grounded in the real world here we spend
most of the run time exploring the
civilization that evolved in the secret
Universe underneath our own Janet calls
it subatomica and it resembles a Star
Wars prequel Planet more than anything
we've seen in the MCU director Peyton
Reed has held episodes of the
Mandalorian so this likely isn't by
accident Kang City features countless
circular designs while his ship and its
energy core have a similar aesthetic
though none of these words or phrases
are used in the movie this is probably
the mcu's version of chronopolis Kang's
Fortress and home base King's ship
resembles the ship in his first
appearance in Avengers number eight and
the engine core could be based on the
forever Crystal or the light of the
century sphere the MCU seems to be
unifying the look and function of any of
its matchable objects
most death scenes are played for drama
but that's not the case with Modoc the
mechanized organism designed only for
killing is actually a not quite dead
Darren cross recovered by Kang after
Ant-Man sent yellowjacket into the
quantum realm in the first Ant-Man movie
modak is loyal to Kang for saving his
life but the movie makes it clear that
Kang barely gives his grotesque kenchman
the time of day a repentant but fatally
wounded Darren tries to have a warm
fuzzy moment with Hank his former mentor
and Scots his former rival telling them
that they were like family before
declaring himself an Avenger he also
notices that hope has changed her hair
most of this awkwardly comedic scene
calls back to the complicated
relationships between Hank hope Darren
and Scots from the first Ant-Man this
one-liner however is a reference to the
comics and the second film the MCU has
blurred the lines between the comics
versions of Janet and hope making Janet
older and more of a supporting presence
while giving hope many of Janet's
characteristics from The Source material
Hope's new Shaggy pixie haircuts and her
more pigmented high contrast black and
yellow super suit are both more comics
accurate than how the character was
portrayed in Ant-Man and the wasp thank
you
by far the most talked about Easter eggs
and Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania can
be found in the post-credits scenes the
first of which makes good on a promise
that now two different variants have
made in Loki he who remains warns out of
Sylvie chooses to kill him the void of
his absence would be filled by something
much worse More Kings when Ant-Man the
wasp and is suited up Cassie try to
conquer the Conqueror he too suggests
that the Multiverse is a more stable
place under his thumb that it would be
in the midst of all-out multiversal War
sure seems like Scott and hope killed
the king imprisoned in the quantum realm
and in the mid credit stinger and Arena
full of Kings reacts to the news this is
the Council of Kings a massive group
that assembles in the comics to deal
with problem variants the storyline
unfolds and Avengers numbers
267-269. the final shot of the
mid-credit Stinger is a faithful
Recreation of an especially creepy panel
depicting the Council of cross time
Kings which isn't exactly the same thing
as a council of Kings an
interdimensional Council of reeds would
follow in Fantastic Four number 570 and
famously Rick and Morty would ape the
idea at the Council of Ricks hey what do
you know it's a cowboy version of me
geez you're easy to impress Rick and
Morty writer Jeff lovnes wrote the
script for Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania and is currently slated to
pen the upcoming Avengers the Kang
Dynasty for Marvel Studios
while there are what looks to be
hundreds of kangs in the mid-credit
Stinger three variants take Center Stage
their alter egos advertise big thanks to
Common Kings and in the mcu's future one
of these variants is dressed like an
ancient Egyptian pharaoh this is
undoubtedly Rama Tut a variant of
Nathaniel Richards who time traveled
back to Egypt in about 2900 BC and
became their Godlike ruler Pharaoh Rama
Tut's plot intertwines with those of
Moon Knight as well as Dr Strange the
X-Men and the Fantastic Four in the
middle of the trio stands a king wearing
a tall headpiece and a large neck piece
we can safely guess that this is
immortus a future iteration of Kang who
often battles his younger selves and the
Avengers immortus commands the
timekeepers in the comics as he Lords
over the realm of limbo from which he
can come and go as he pleases the
identity of the third Kang variants is
less obvious it could be either Scarlet
Centurion or iron lad but he doesn't
perfectly match the comic description of
either so it's possible he could be a
different character from the comics or a
new character created for the MCU
season one of Loki ends as the title
character realizes what he who remains
predicted has indeed come to pass Loki
runs to tell Mobius who no longer
remembers who is Prisoner slash partner
is Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania ends
with a post-credit scene that serves as
a teaser for Loki season 2. see you soon
a man played by Jonathan Majors is
giving some sort of scientific
demonstration in what appears to be
early 1900s America in the crowd we spot
Loki he seems to feel some sense of
accomplishment at having Tracked Down
The Man on stage but he looks worried
nonetheless the man standing next to him
is revealed to be Mobius and he doesn't
understand What's So Scary About the
steampunky looking huckster not only
does this post-credit Stinger set up a
possible mission for the duo in Loki
season 2 but it also confirms that
another important Kang variant will be a
factor going forward the gentleman
they've located across time and space is
likely Victor timely a Kang variant who
travels to 1901 and uses his Limitless
knowledge to become a powerful
industrialist the first season of Loki
leaned hard into its mid-center revives
and it will be interesting if season 2
Embraces more of a turn of the century
aesthetic beyond that the Dapper Victor
timely would make an excellent foil to
the Charming god of mischief